now this brings us to tonight's Hannity
hot seat and joining us now attorney
Daryl parks along with the president of
the national fallen officers Foundation
retired Dallas Police Sergeant Trey
penny is with us Daryl gadabi back Trey
good to have you back
um Daryl I just read all the statistics
I just told you the truth I just gave
you the academic studies so you tell me
all these people that are claiming five
black officers one black suspect killed
which was horrific we all saw it I do
believe that there rightly will be
justice but explain to me how they raced
to the no pun intended how they run to
the race narrative immediately
Sean I probably can't explain that at
all but what I will tell you though is
like you just said the truth matters I
think the conversation should really be
about dash cam and body Cam and how
those types of things actually bring
transparency both to law enforcement and
to the community but wait a minute but
this is that's the topic the topic here
is simple why do people take a case that
involves five black officers one black
suspect and turn it into a race case now
there's going to be a civil rights
investigation you represent a Trayvon
Martin's family that did not happen in
your case did it
no it didn't it didn't and let me say
this here probably injected a race into
this case takes away from the
conversation of tariq's life right and
the bigger conversation that we all
could be having about safety without
throughout our country for example Sean
in my state alone we still have
Sheriff's departments that reject body
Cam and dash cam and so in our
communities we're going to be asking
about what are we doing in our community
that's a better conversation that would
give some benefit to what happened to
Tariq and do what was very responsible
that the people in Memphis and had done
here
all right let's get your your uh take on
this trade penny
look Sean the bottom line is you got a
lot of people that want to play into
this victim mentality that's what that's
what the Democrat Party is doing is
really they're going to the to the black
community and they're trying to get them
up in arms about uh an issue that that
happens very and think about this we got
over uh 700 000 police officers in this
country that have uh thousands and
thousands of interactions with police
every every day and you very seldom hear
these type of situations that happen
because they happen only point zero zero
one percent of the time so we got to
make sure that we are putting this whole
thing in context and we are addressing
the issue that they as they are now I
will say this Sean this is really what
they're trying to do they're trying to
promote this George Floyd Bill uh they
want to go they want to get it on paper
that they can put these consent decrees
in place for law enforcement across the
country so they can have uh take
qualified immunity from police officers
because they want to be able to
prosecute us every time they look around
that's why you have less people less and
less more
um I want to go into the profession
you're the head of the fallen officers
Association on average how many many
police officers do we lose every year
how many did we lose last year how many
did we lose in 2020 and 2021
yeah no look we we're losing and Kobe
kind of threw the numbers off we had
about 600 last year but if you look at
the actual line of duty deaths we're
losing about 200 150 offers every year
uh so we got to make sure that we are
qualifying uh what's happening with law
enforcement now look I asked I asked
Congress last year that we needed the
same level of protection that they're
talking about uh silver we got civil
rights violations that are put in place
when police officers go out and do
something to the community and they can
they can prosecute officers federally
but what happens when individuals attack
police officers and the state drops the
drops drops the ball then why can't we
go and file in the federal court and
have them to protect law enforcement
Daryl can you name one officer who lost
his life in the line of duty in the last
three years
I I thought well actually that's the one
lost his life right here in Cairo
Georgia over the weekend so yes uh do
you know the name of one officer can you
name one officer
his name was his first name was Clarence
yes I can but it's not a contest about
me Sean I think let me ask you this
conversation this is the next question
and that is do you support this Insanity
of defund dismantle no bail laws does it
make American cities and towns less does
it make cities less Town less safe and
towns uh less safe or more safe
I don't support that let me see what I
support Sean I think the issue with
mental health in this country right has
to be addressed at its core that's what
we haven't done until we address
Comprehensive Mental Health almost all
these mass shootings involve some high
level of mental health that should be
the discussion and no one is having that
type of discussion that's what I'm for
oh I don't know how mental health came
into this this discussion
so we have a culture issue and I just
want to be honest with everybody look
I'm from the black community I'm in the
black community actively in the black
community across the country and I'm
trying to do what I can to change the
culture guys we have a culture issue
that we need to fix we allow criminals
to come in and victimize us and then
what do we do on the other side
politically we're going to Advocate to
get those victims out of jail and they
come back home and victimize us more we
got to do so we got to stop doing that
because we're hurting the people that
live in these communities some people
can't pack up and and go leave and go
move to the suburbs like most of us can
the reality is people got to sit here
and they got to live amongst these
violent offenders we need to start
taking care of the people and I'm asking
everybody if you're watching this
channel to get behind me and helping us
the national fall and also foundation
advocating for the entrance of law
enforcement advocate for the interest of
these communities so we can keep
everybody safe and protect law
enforcement as a whole all right thank
you both Trey Penny Daryl Parks we
appreciate it and hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else